the idea that this of this evening also
was born in my so-called lab of art and
architecture that is not was not written
on the poster but this is the reality
and in this capacity I thought that
there was nothing better I could do then
to invite macketryck martine and michael
craig martin thought that he would
invite him as he's a interlocutor for
this evening and that's how this
formation came about now Michael as his
full name Micha craig martin is one of
those happy creatures who did not have
to invent his name like many others in
architecture as he became a painter he
had his name already made for him we
used to call him in the early days of
course with sincerity always MCM never
in his full name and spittle birthdays
remarked that the acronyms of this kind
usually gives the carrier a greater
strength like us are like us SL well in
case of USA I didn't work exactly how it
was planned but I'm saying it because
michael is one of those rare artists
that not only knows himself so well but
exceptionally also able to know others
which is very rare among all human
beings but sometimes even especially so
when it comes to art and architecture
because after all the task of being an
artist Oh an architect is so demanding
that quite often even if you were not
born artistic you become one as a kind
of self defense and Michael is this rare
creature who as much as he has done for
his own paintings which by now establish
his work so prominently in the world he
has done almost as much for other people
art precisely for no other reason than
the love of it we used to always make
these strange remarks about they eat
that only some of us felt we understood
you know we were just talking about last
night the privilege of being in a studio
with young people totally unknown nobody
heard of them or their work and
confronted with the work one had to say
without any help as it were is it it or
is it not and being able to say yes this
is it was all that was needed in fact
you know people that some of you perhaps
would know I member particular Tony
Creek Tony Cragg showing me a pile of
stones and asking me he stepped it and I
say yes that's it yes again you da is
that it I said yes that's it and then
the third time and some time we felt
that there was nothing more important
than doing precisely that being there
and being confronted with works that had
no description that well could not be
could not be known in any way certainly
not in advance so for this experience
that in fact we have such a
extraordinary people already in their
70s in the early days of coldness in
there we knew what we were doing then
only in the 80s late 80s that
came kind of public knowledge and so we
thought that there that the entire
trajectory of that moment is his worth
understanding a little bit better and
it's worth making this understanding a
little bit more public and this is the
object of these exercises this evening
so we'll have two parts the first part
will be introduction or off Liam and
then a dialogue for followed by question
discussion and that's how you end the
evening so hey I invite you very good
but we could actually have the lights
down and begin with an image I think
because my introduction is going to be
extremely short and it's really going to
be to try and explain why we're here
other than the it factor which I was
actually subject to or a subject of
having been a student at Goldsmiths in
the early 80s and what's interesting
from from what was said is that of
course this was already a place with the
kind of reputation and it already there
was already a rumor around that that
this was a place of ideas in the place
of possibilities now one thing that's
very crucial which isn't to deny the
profound effect of educational
institutions and art schools and
architecture schools is that one of the
reasons is that the artists who were
working there were doing something that
their work was in the world that they
had what now is kind of a negative
connotation which is a career but a
career in in the 70s in art especially
in England didn't actually have the
negative connotation of money because
there was no money around but a career
meant actually having sustained presence
and an ongoing practice so what I wanted
to do is really move quite rapidly into
a an exchange which really is going to
be Michael's thing and I'm really here
to
to prod him to try and interrupt to ask
some questions to try to maybe leave
some gaps in the discussion for later on
so some people can enter into what in a
way is going to be quite complicated
because we're really looking at at a
specific history of work over the last
45 years and we're also looking there's
the danger because we're going to have
to be considering the built world at
least if not specific architecture that
the talk like this is going to sort of
slip in between that it'll slip in
between in a non productive way to build
slip in between the the focus and the
often perverse practice of trying to
think about how to make art or trying to
make it or come up with that kind of
moment and a more sophisticated
contemporary discourse about the
potential of architecture so what I
thought was very important is that we
start in a way at the beginning of the
story that while it seems sometimes dumb
to keep to make things chronological I
think it's very important and pressed
Michael yesterday that we had some I
don't know early work is technically
correct but for me it's um it's never
really early because the most of this
work was destroyed right at some point
in a way we could start with the fire
that's always a good way to start but I
mean do you there's a number of images
here at the beginning that maybe you
could just go through them and to say
some details some some information this
is always useful what are we looking at
well I'm when when you and I spoke
yesterday we decided that we need that
we I needed some kind of introduction
about the work that precedes most of
what we're going to talk about to give
you some idea about what I was thinking
and and very much about the kind of
thinking that led me to where I got to
next which leads to wearing it to next
which all looks very logical in
retrospect but as you're doing it
doesn't always look look that way I mean
there was something that which sort of a
tokiya to start at the beginning there
was something that I forgot two men
tu Liem last night and I wonder and I
don't even know if he realizes this but
I was a student at Yale I was very very
lucky in the early 60s and there was a
project that we were given by Al held
which was to do architectural
interventions in the new rudolph
building the am a building was the
second year that the building was open
and i did two interventions because i
liked it and one of them I'm I would be
proud to do today the other one not so
much so and I won't mention that but day
was very happy to do it the interest the
things that reason I mentioned it is
because I obviously had that interest of
some connectedness with architecture at
a time when the eat there was no name
for this kind of work it had no have
nope it was no a real model for such a
thing in the way that we were doing it
and also i have to say that it took me
about 20 or 30 years to be given the
next opportunity to do so my life might
been quite different if I had had the
opportunities to go on to do that
immediately but it took many many years
and then when the opportunities came I
did them and of course that's also sell
you happens about to an artist which is
that you start off you start off with
something and then years later it turns
out to be useful just as you're starting
to forget that you actually know about
that it turns out to be something that
can be used to your advantage we're just
going to show I'm just going to a couple
of images of early work this is my work
from my first exhibition it's from 1969
and it's four boxes and I showed because
it shows you something about the way i
think i took the four identical boxes
and i cut lids out of the boxes each one
getting progressively bigger and then
switched the lids around so that the by
the thing that interested me was that
what I did was so uninteresting and that
the result is more interesting than the
description of what I did that what the
consequences the consequence overrides
the the actual thing that's been
the other thing that interested me very
much which is tied in with the question
of architecture is the fact that in
general works of art are the one thing
you're not supposed to do is touch them
and by making boxes that it hinged lids
you are it was I was trying to build
into it the forbidden thing that you had
to touch it in order for the work to
work as this is now in a museum even I
am going to be arrested if I try to
touch it but the thought is there that
was the idea this is work from the early
70s I think it Mona speaks for itself
and it has to do with obviously with the
reversal of certain expectations I got
interested in the idea of ordinary
objects and also very interested in the
idea that the thing that defines objects
is functionality so I try to always play
on the question of functionality this is
another worked in this one there's a
tabletop with those pulleys on the
ceiling that's rope went up to the
pulleys and then down to the buckets the
four buckets are filled with water and
the water weighs exactly the same amount
is the table top so the tabletop is held
in suspension just under the buckets so
in a sense the things on the table are
supporting the table now this this is an
oak tree which is the work for which I'm
become the work that I'm best known for
its become strangely iconic it's had its
had a whole life of its own it travels
around the world without me it's been
there's a text that the objects when it
was first shown it was this was the only
thing shown in the gallery and then
there was a text that people were handed
and the text takes the form of an
interview with mice with myself I don't
have a copy with here so i'm going to
show to you and i'll just read the first
few lines but you'll get the idea if you
don't know what you get the idea to
begin with could you describe this work
yes of course what i've done is to
change a glass of water into a
full-grown oak tree without altering the
accidents of the glass of water the
accidents yes the color feel wait sighs
do you mean that the glass of water is a
symbol of an oak tree no it's not a
simple I've changed the physical
substance of the glass of water into
that of an oak tree it looks like a
glass of water of course it does I
didn't change its appearance but it's
not a glass of water it's an oak tree
the text continues clean so I think this
was very important to kind of establish
something and what what I'm curious
about is that you've talked about this
idea of work being an endless
progression of starts and you already
see this this is the period we've just
seen is a very kind of there's a lot
more work from this time but but there's
something very singular about each piece
which is rather uncommon even in that
point the idea of cereal production the
idea of finding an idea and projecting
it into the future the idea of having a
rhetorical framework around the work
that could then protect you into a
future seems to be completely broken
down in your work that while it
certainly if you showed these images to
someone and said could you date these
could you tell us from which period in
history are they from they might not be
far off there is this feeling of this
kind of starting again like like this
idea of this progression of starts in a
way did he talk about is that we looking
for something that could be the thing or
were you actively trying to start again
all the time I I had an idea first of
all of the idea of trying to be stylist
I didn't want to be identified with I
didn't want to be cornered I saw at the
time I saw a lot of artists as being
cornered into what it was that they were
known to do and one sees this all the
time that you have a sense that some
artists are able to make what they do
expansive and some artists really appear
to be rather trapped and in in what
they're in what's expected of them and
so I was trying to make something that
was essentially stylist on the other
hand i was also try i was what i really
wanted to do which I could never achieve
and part of that was because I was
spending so much of my life also
teaching and I have no money was that I
wanted to be able to do different things
simultaneously
I wanted to have several different it
wasn't that I wanted them all to be they
ended up being much more separate and
compartmentalize and I have to say that
one things that happens the worker
you'll see is that this stops and the
reason was because it was driving me
crazy I was very very unhappy and very
it was so exhausting trying to work in
this way because everything I produced
stopped me mm-hmm every day I could gain
nothing I could take me I could take so
little from each thing into the next
thing that I was constantly as liam says
starting and that is not really a
wonderful way to live your life 30 could
you can you move on to the next image
because I'm i want to see it'll it
should go they go so then suddenly I
mean this we're jumping and skipping for
the sake of a way of proceeding but what
strikes me about the earlier work is the
ideas in themselves can function not
regardless of place but the place
they're done in doesn't seem terribly
significant it could be anywhere it
could be any kind of space and then
suddenly there's this shift did you
think at this point that you were
finding a way to was that what was
missing if you see what I mean what can
you identify what was missing in this
sense of starting again all the time
because to a certain extent it's a kind
of still used as an ethical test by
artists or some kind of strange thing
the idea it's very common thing to have
a discussion with someone that Oh
someone's doing what they always do are
they doing it again or they're repeating
themselves or they always do this this
is always a kind of anxiety about is
this idea of it's almost a kind of
perverse inverse of of of an archetype
of commercial architects problems that
it's it's it's the thing that you need
and it's the thing that is a kind of
nightmare at the same time if you
describe the nightmare of constant
started starts as a problem well the
constant repetition is a problem too so
where does suddenly you're working on
the wall suddenly there are buildings
involved suddenly there's spaces well
the other most important thing that that
change because there is about five or
six years between the last slide and
this one was a transition
from all the previous work used real
objects and one of the things again in
relation to this start and stop thing
that I found with buzz happening and
what I was doing was that in a way when
you use a real like when I used the
glass of water for an oak tree I had
used up the glass of water as a it I
couldn't turn to it again because it was
if I did I instead of enhancing what I
had done i undermined what I had done
and so my out of this dilemma that i
created for myself i decided to try just
drawing the things that i had previously
used so i start to draw individual
objects and I drew them each what I drew
them all on the same size sheet of paper
and I drew one at a time I just drew
every day I just drew another one and I
would do on acetate I would do it an
outline in tape that was because what I
wanted was was a kind of drawing that
was again stylist as I had wanted in the
beginning and something that just gave
you just gave you information something
and something that kind of drawing that
was very like the manufactured objects
themselves I wanted the drawing not to
have the character of art but to have
the character of the object and the
object was manufactured so I'm under the
drawing to look man you injured be if
you've written before that you had this
or you have felt this kind of commitment
to simple and direct and and what what
is it that would make someone feel that
way I mean what what is it about simple
and direct what is it what what does
that do as a function of art in relation
to a space like this which i see'em is a
gallery but well look at the floor and
the slough Seawolves I'm mistaken before
well the one of the things that happens
is as soon as you move away from a real
object into images of objects I suddenly
start to understand certain things about
why artists have done in history what
they've done why do they do this why do
they make pictures of things and one of
the reasons is because they're so
unbelievably flexible so you can make
something the artists of the IMP of the
things well the thing is flexible so it
allows the artist a degree of
flexibility because you can make them
gigantic an you
make them tiny I did small drawings took
slides of them which made them even
smaller blew the slide up in the wall
and then drew on the wall with tape and
I found that I was I had found a way to
make gigantic things that had absolutely
no substance no physicality you could
the whole thing just exists a bit of
tape on the wall at the end of them of
the expression you just pulled the tape
of the world's a little ball news throw
it away and there was something so
magnificent about the economy of that
that there was was you could you could
have all the characteristics but you
mean literal economy as well because you
would have just a bunch of sheets of
paper and some tape as well as being
artistic economy yes and that made you
because of course the irony of certain
kind of poster champion artists of
course you do end up worrying about do I
keep these specific bottles or do I have
to get this particular shelving system
again I mean was there a crisis of a
conceptual crisis at some point in their
work do you think cuz strangely well
while these works for me in a way you
could technically say well they're a
kind of return to picturing or drawing
or something that might be from an
earlier whatever we could call earlier
moment yet somehow they're strangely
freer than the things were you having a
conceptual crisis is it way well I don't
I think at this time I mean I i was
still in that situation where i ii was
every day i was just learning something
from the process and finding out things
that I hadn't that I hadn't anticipated
I mean my idea was with the drawings
that drawing was so basic I would just
go back to the most basic thing and
start again and of course is when you do
that you know you know what in a sense
that is what happens you do start and
you start to untie me one of the things
that's very interesting about
discovering things in art is that you
can discover something that people have
known for centuries but if you discover
it it's your discovery I mean unless you
have it it's not a discovery of you it's
when you have it that it becomes one and
that was more less what was happening
for me the other thing was that without
really necessarily
intending it all the drawings because
they were on a state became templates
and so I've only ever drawn one open
book and that was in 1978 and that's it
and then all my work up to now I used
the same drawer in the book I've never
drawn another book open I've never drawn
another safety pin I've never drawn
another flashlight all these these
images have become templates and I've
just added to this vocabulary of things
we yeah we should can get and move move
on so so then this is the this is in a
way this is the British school in Rome
right yes at some point and it's
interesting reading Richard cork is a
very well respected British art critic
wrote a rather exciting essay about
Michael for a book by Tom's and Hudson a
few years ago which is actually very
interesting to keep searching for like
daggers and sharp things and scary stuff
in the work in order almost to try and
make it seem more scary or more profound
but of course with this work you do get
what I'd call or which you've also
talked about as the in a way the first
overt acknowledgment that you're in a
room that's been designed by someone and
built by someone that seems to me very
striking regardless of what you think
about the work or judge about the work
in terms of an artistic act that it's a
it's a it's a turning point for me
because up to that point even though
large wall drawings seem to be possible
in in many types of location and
suddenly here we have a work that is
specific it seems to be it relies on the
room itself it accepts the fireplace as
part of the work it accepts the doors
the lights and so on suddenly there are
these decisions that have to be made can
you talk a little bit about that well
what you're describing is exactly the
way I felt about about it because what
when I had done with the wall drawings
is I felt I had didn't I had created a
kind of work that I could take to any
place and make it make it become part of
that place you simply projected and if
the world was was 25 feet high you made
the drawing 25 feet high and if it were
if you could only go 6-foot you went 6
foot so the same work would it just
simply adjust
to the base but it was never know none
of the works were ever done for a
particular place and this was the first
time I ever made a work that was
specific to the room but do you think
there was this feeling that the
potential of a kind of pure almost pure
conceptual practice which often has this
potential that's what it is it is
potential a Lawrence weena is potential
you have the potential to carry out his
kind of instruction or to write it on
the wall or read it in a book but
effectively we know it has become a kind
of rather stable Orthodox presentation
that in fact people don't want to do
them any size they never do them really
small they only do them as big as
possible or something we we you was this
a sort of around the time that you did
this we you did this was this a freeing
moment because in a slightly like kind
of dodgy evangelical preacher you could
accept the real the built world into
your life or something like well what
seems to be an acknowledgement that
there might be a limit to this potential
of conceptual practice well the the the
thing that I that happened was there was
this room and it was in Rome and it was
a room there was a room that obviously
had a history and the history of the
room had nothing to do with being an art
gallery obviously had been because on
the other side the rumor of French doors
out to a tennis court so we've got the
end were there were two fireplaces these
grand fireplaces and the room had so
much character and so many of the things
that artists do were in rooms that have
so little character it just seemed to me
that it was crazy not to try to play on
that so that's what I try to do and the
minute that and this was also the first
time I ever introduced color and I ever
painted the wall I never I better use
paint in this way and everything changed
my whole career change completely design
ever ever went back to the other thing
it all changed with this from then on I
used color and I use painted rooms and I
made everything became specific to a
place because that enabled me to
introduce a kind not only specificity in
terms of the place possessed specificity
in terms of me in relation to that place
which had never occurred
the work before too maybe we should
maybe we should move through a few
things and just maybe you can just tell
us where they are and yeah you know like
maybe a little technical stuff like how
it's done or what you know have you
there's this moment of you with the
acetate and the and the roll of tape and
a overhead projector so when you're
shifting and like how is this done for
example where is this this is it this is
a painting in Tokyo and this was one of
the first works in the in this work you
can say the images are more or less
life-size and they're more or less
naturalistic in color the background is
very vivid but the objects are not and
but this is a painting on canvas and in
order to get the tape to do its thing on
to do the equivalent line that I had
been using which I didn't want to lose
it involves painting the whole thing
black then doing all the drawing first
then paint you all the colors on it and
then you remove the tape at the end and
that's how I do absolutely everything
everything is drawn the tape but the
tape always has to precede the work you
always have to paint the color you want
it to be and you have to paint a big
area of color you know to draw it so
then so this is not produced by I mean
this could be produced by a big company
and silk screening company somewhere it
could be industrially produced or it I
could think it's a bit early for good
inkjet but yes it was a little before
that it was what what's going on there
as a daily practice I mean yours you
standing in a room painting it or you
standing it yes I was in my studio and
it wrapped around three walls of my
maestria was very big moment around
three balls and the amazing thing is
that it took me you know I spent nearly
half a year a year to do it now I may I
think don't you know I would think to
make about ten things de sized now
because of changes in my own ability and
also changes in the technology of how
things with what you can do but at the
time I was so overwhelmed by the scale
of it that and the and the unknown pneus
of what I was doing I mean going back to
that thing we were talking about about
how things get that sense of the
additive mess of things it's very
interesting that for because and they're
part of the dilemma for an artist is
that the repetitiveness of things in a
growing moment is the thing that's
fabulous and then suddenly sometimes
pretty quickly it goes dead and it's
just repetition there's that funny but
you've said you know you've said before
the Europe pose to self expression which
is of course it's a good line and i like
it and i think i agree with it up to a
point but it's a very complicated thing
to say when I think it's something you
can say about yourself maybe in and it's
hard to say about other people and feel
safe but but of course you're working in
these cases there's a lot of labor
involved so there seems to be this
difference between like where is this
difference between expression and labor
it seems in a way quite there's this
idea that an artist is supposed to work
because you're they mean well my idea
about self-expression is that
essentially I don't like the term
self-expression because it seems me that
it always implies that you that the
artist has something to express to
somebody else it's like giving something
and I think that suffix real self
expression is the bit that happens that
expresses something about yourself that
you can't resist that happens anyway and
you even when you try to resist it you
can't it's not that you try to put it in
and it's not that you try to take it out
yet just the character of my work says
everything about what I'm like really
and I think that's true of every artist
but I don't think that's what's meant in
general when people talk about
self-expression mm-hmm so whereas this
this is in the country and in Dusseldorf
and this was the first time that I took
the colors from the walls the bright
colors and put them into the objects and
also start to play with the scale of the
images which of course why when you're
doing images should you make them all
life-size that make no sense
this is in the Prince Ryne in Hannover
in in the country on there there were
nine rooms and what I did for the
exhibition was each one of the rooms was
painted a different color there were
imaged two images in each room and two
older works for every room but yet there
was something yes something I just want
to say which happens in these what I
discovered when I started to paint the
rooms these very vivid colors well and
add images was that i'm introducing
pictures into the work but one of the
things that happened was that the things
in the room like the doors the windows
the radiators the light switches somehow
became pictorial eyes as they became
more and more unreal looking just and
that whereas the images start to take on
a kind of presence in reality so this
became much more play between the day
architectural accidents in the room and
the images is that the same these are
all in the same this is this going from
room to room in the same
you
I mean one of the questions I already
hate is when people ask me to talk about
color because to me it seems like such a
it's other people who talk about color
you know I've worked on a few projects
recently where collaborative projects
with with people where they've asked me
if I could talk through my color or I
could speak to the color or something
and frankly what I'm doing is like a lot
of people here as I'm color picking or
I'm working in in pallets on the
computer and functioning that way but
one of the most disturbing things I
think about a shift in your work around
this time which I think even certain
people were quite reluctant to bring up
was this sudden devastating in a way in
a positive sense hideous use of color
which seems to be so at odds with the
idea of taste with in art even within a
kind of post conceptual practice it
seems so wrong and so countered that
there even the general aesthetic of the
museum or the gallery how how did that
what was happening those this to do with
a shift toward suddenly using a computer
do you think or is it coming before that
one has say that the computer is or this
is all we're in the early mid 90s and
this is already the computer app seek
it's the most critical thing that
happened in my work was the was the
computer because suddenly all the things
that I have been doing that had taken
ages and ages to plan and to do I could
do them so wonderfully on the computer
was like was just designed for me and
what happened with their color was my
first when I had tried to play with
color before and it was always kind of
namby-pamby kind of little hesitant
about it because I said like many others
have ended quite frightening and I as
when I started to do these rooms I
discovered that you could buy this is
all the rooms here are painted both
house hoping you brought down the shop
and I and I realized that you could get
just these amazing colors and they look
really amazing you put a lot of them
together but you could get very very
intense vivid color kind of color I
didn't associate with being able to
paint your house and why do they make so
many colors I'd
I don't quite understand it very very
few people use these colors i can tell
you i mean very and certainly
fortunately very few people use them in
their homes not and and I don't either
unless I want to brush to tell you I
don't live like this either but it never
I wasn't my intention to make something
beautiful with my intention was to make
something vivid and I also like the idea
just as I never draw anything you can't
name I never try anything that you have
to figure out what it is i would never
draw a nice bit of plumbing equipment
you think oh that's what's interesting
drawing I just if you can't call it
something it's a watch it's a book it's
a table a chair I don't draw it and so I
thought well the colors should be the
same red green yellow pink blue they
should have a name should not need to
speculate I I'm trying to remove
speculation from certain obvious the
certain areas where it could sit and get
it somewhere else so and so then I
discovered that I fell upon this palette
of incredibly vivid colors I I got end
and of course the really ridiculous
thing is that I when I was a student I
was at Yale and I studied the alborz
color of course I don't know if anybody
does the alborz co-workers anymore but
suddenly in another miracle place it
became unbelievably useful and
everything I know about color I learned
from Joseph compras for that color
course and i use it all now I everything
every time I think about it that's it
gives me away and I never had any idea
how to use color before I surges and
then but I also realized was people went
to these places and were happy people
went in and smiled and it had never
occurred to me that people would go to
suddenly just walk through a place and
have it wasn't their emotion in his in a
kind of deep dramatic way but an emotion
in a very touching simple way that
people's mood was changed by the by the
experience of these things and that
struck me as a very extraordinary thing
I never even occur to me that such a
thing would happen and this happened
because of the color I also say that
because the people who
my people obviously see my work is
divided into the color work and the non
color work all the non color work is
considered reasonably conceptual and all
the postcard work is considered
hopelessly non-conceptual whereas but do
you think it's something to do with the
fact that it's possible to say that that
in a way the work suddenly becomes
indifferent or like strangely kind of
positively indifferent to art and
positively and different to architecture
which is a very odd position to be in
does that make sense that the way now
for example in a situation where at
least for the last 20 years any decent
artistic practice that makes
self-conscious ironic relationships to
the failure of modernism or to the
yearning for like high-end mid-century
public housing for example is is viewed
possibly correctly is good and and a
very good artistic practice and equally
on the other on the other hand any
developed architectural practice that
shows a kind of going beyond the limits
of the traditional notion of where our
kicks are supposed to be and supposed to
reside is also seen as positive this
works strangely enough seems to it is
this kind of radical indifference in a
way which I find quite interesting I
mean maybe you can talk about this it's
so almost a perfect illustration of it
and also for me striking is always a
reminder at how Gordy and ridiculous and
kitschy medieval why the past worms yeah
the past was if you see what I mean
assuming that we're looking here at what
I think we're looking at which is it is
it's a small medieval Museum in books to
huda in Germany and that they have two
collections one of modernist chairs at
the other of of medieval carved
sculpture and they mix them so it seemed
to me perfectly reasonable for me to add
a few things and but but there's
something else that I started to realize
as doing these these
things I mean I came to the this work
with these stupid drawings and one of
the things that I realized is that
architecture is virtually by its nature
abstract and you know occasionally you
get a building that looks like a hot dog
but other than that it is not
architecture is not representational and
one what is what hat what happens I
think I've found some odd corner for
myself of taking this end of these
representations of things and inserting
them into an intern into an
architectural context that do something
that's difficult to put your finger on
exactly what happens and that have
because they get because an image gives
you scale it gives you associate gives
you certain things certain kinds of
richness of something even when it's the
simplest thing and I'm not trying to do
anything very much here but it but they
have an impact and and it seems that's
struck me as very curious in but there
is there I mean there is a specific
reference though that I you know if I
remember in the mid-80s you mentioned an
architect to me and you talked to me
about this Mexican architect he'd done
like amazing pink buildings and it was
pre-internet and the library at
Goldsmiths wasn't that great and so and
I couldn't quite remember the name of
the person so I actually spent the next
15 years dreaming about this fantasy
Mexican architect he'd done pink
buildings until the internet arrived and
then I could actually google him and but
if you go to the barragan house for
example in Mexico City there is this
kind of hotness about the color but this
this is a specific example cuz of course
you also get this Catholic aspect to the
work in the sense of literal Chris fixes
and mementos and bits and pieces and do
you feel that that rather than
being influenced maybe by my structure
that you might have been was barragan
someone that influenced you or you're
aware of or was this something that
became a coincidence in a way no I was
definitely I knew about paragon Meredith
a new event for a long time and I and I
was absolutely floored when I first saw
his architecture and I and they use a
his use of color at they had a kind of
architectural scale I knew of other
examples of course in Dutch architecture
and various in Corbusier and other
modernist architects but but the the use
of color in marion was so extraordinary
and that certainly had an influence on
me again attempting to do something
similar I i have to say i always think i
mean i like the fact that you brought up
the fact that my work is in such bad
taste and I and I because I always think
of certain people you know and certainly
most architects don't seek bad taste and
and certainly he doesn't and I think
it's one of the things that's different
it is an artist you're allowed a bit of
bad taste well it was very striking I
mean I what I found most striking in
that house actually is that and I don't
know why I hadn't thought of it before
but there are things that I'd seen in
photographs that I thought were a
Picasso or a Mondrian or a real one and
actually turn out to just be framed
posters in in fancy old frames and its
really striking it's the most the most
perverse thing about that house is the
fact that he has an amazing collection
of art from the 20th century but it's
all like posters from like faded posters
from from some Museum in the middle of
nowhere or you know from from the museum
modern art that are just framed in fancy
frames its extreme very extreme and this
of course brings a stiff to this
particular image which in a way shows
the I think the perversity of things
other than art frankly where's the time
so could you tell us about this this is
this is in this small museum in books
and hood of the needless to say the
curator is rather eccentric and the
crucifix
the one of the things that was just
amazing weather is why they loved me and
wanted me to do this and it was supposed
to be there for two months and that was
12 years ago and they have maintained
what I did perfectly although it was
part of a temporary exhibition there the
room is about this they're engaged in
the study of a paint of painted objects
which as a medieval study and this
extraordinary contraption is from some
kind of medical practice which is not
it's not a dentist drill but it's it's
got glasses that you looked at it
magnifies and it's aimed at a tiny chip
paint on Christ knee so you can view if
you look through it you can get you and
you can see the different layers of
color and so I thought it for me to add
a fire extinguisher was perfectly
reasonable so I'm quite conscious of
time and I think it's important I want
to see everything so I think we should
try and move a little I'll interrupt
okay I think it's great timing okay this
this is the I did all these consequence
friends I was on a kind of concern role
this is a stuttgart which is an immense
room circular room and it's about five
or six meters high the green wall and
then does unbelievable dome above it so
what year is this do you think this is
in right earnest 97 98
that's right and this was the first this
was the first time that I use images of
other of I took images that of artists
who'd you drew use real objects to make
ready-mades and then I did the drawings
of their work as the ready-mades to put
them kind of back into my work mm-hmm so
the jasper johns and Duchamp and migrate
and then this this is the the museum in
in valencia they have a wing of the
museum which it's not actually a true
building it looks like it is but in fact
it's it's architectural remnants that
have been assembled to make a kind of
ecclesiastical room but you can see this
mixtures of styles here in mixtures of
architecture but it makes a fantastic
space in which to do something and in
this place I mixed old work with new
work you can see on the purple wall is
the oak tree and then there's the
buckets and then painted the room and
the painting which is in what would
which is which implies it's in the
sacristy is actually based on last
meninas there's the canvas the fire
extinguisher is the artist the
sunglasses are the princess the belt is
that the belt the belt is the dog the
pencil sharpener is the dwarf the ladder
is the men coming through the doorway
and of course is the mirror for the king
and queen this is the same
so by the time things are getting to
this scale in this extent you know in
the the big shows and stood garten
wherever how things being done are you
you still he's still there up a ladder
yeah I mean yeah and valencia was
nightmare of course because it was done
in the summer and when you were on tyler
they had it just call it a cherry picker
in America you know one of those things
that goes up and looking and it was
about 120 degrees at the top of the room
and we were just so to say sometimes the
tape it's all drawn but this is all done
with tape and sometimes the tape just
wouldn't stick because my hands were
dripping I was so wet I couldn't get the
tape to stay on the wall when when you
do this this that what we have to
explain this is in front here is an
earlier work right Frank yes this is
this is another one of the box beach
like the first piece that I showed you
is part for the same and that thing of
mixing I very much my idea of mixing the
old work in the new how could you do
that to yourself oh are you thinking I
think anyone try and stop you now know
you were in there and I think these
curious conjunctions between things are
so extraordinary that I like it when
they're there but it's also fun
sometimes to actually create them to
make something unexpectedly perverse
happen something that because because of
course everything is you know which
we've been talking about really which is
to do with the contextualization of
things the things all these meanings of
things are slipping by all the time I
mean by coincidence we've kind of refer
to the far extreme sir I've used you've
seen it used three times in three
different contexts but has an entirely
different quality it has a different
kind of presence and also a different
kind of meaning Dominion which is the
thing of course that does ultimately
interest me most yeah
and this was in the museum of modern art
in the old entrance way for the last the
last exhibition which for the new
millennium to 2000 I was asked to paint
the until the entire ground floor of the
of the museum and art with image colors
and images and this is just a few I I
took these three objects from the
collection to put together so this is
before their but they're they're
rebuilding it before the rebuilding all
of the all of that not only occurs is
the thing that I've done not there but
the the place itself because all these
rooms no longer exist they've all been
absorbed into the new museum and I
wouldn't even even know where that was
now and then this is a wall drawing done
with tape some paint but merely with
tape in the house to clinched in Munich
and this was one of the first time that
I'd done something like this which is
taking the images floor to ceiling and
having rows of those something I've done
a lot of sense where there's in us in a
sense I'm trying to have something where
there's no hierarchy and the thing
everything everything is equal all the
way and everything is as big as possible
but everything is is contained within
the given height of the sea as though as
though everything is kind of holding up
the ceiling and this is in in dublin in
the Douglas hide gallery of public re in
Dublin and for this which was already a
very large space I decided to make the
images even bigger so the image was so
big they didn't fit
you
and this is in Berlin this is the
British Council library in Berlin you
you entered that the ground floor and
you go up the stairs and on this on the
ceiling I painted for books to open
books and two closed ones but this for
me is like I have a question when we get
to this kind of point up to now
everything's been in the gallery or it's
been in relation to a curatorial present
someone who's invited to you or said you
can do what you want which is of course
the great promise of contemporary art
right that question that statement that
in invitation but in this case the we
suddenly into a different sort of
relationship because this looks like a
place where maybe people don't want to
have a pink book on the ceiling or don't
or there there's going to be another
kind of viewer what I always call the
distracted viewer the one that is
subject to the work as much as being
there intending to see the work they
have to accept that it's there it's a
fact on the ceiling was this how did
this come about mmm it was a commission
but from the British Council I was
hesitant about doing it myself but the
architects saarbruecken Hutton were very
very interested that I would do some
something like this and I mean my I have
to say my family I feeling about works
that I I ever stray do things that
matter how vividly assertive they are
that in a certain sense if you don't
have to look at them you don't and if
you don't look at the ceiling you don't
receive but but how does that I mean is
that was that the first project he did
where where you felt that the you were
being approached or you were being
invited to be part of someone else's
structure in a different way than when
you're doing it in Hitler's favorite
building in museum in Germany which is a
rather different idea there's always
going to be an essential critical
function of art in relation to the haus
der kunst anyway yes contemporary art
here it gets slightly more complicated
you've got the issue of a
of the British Council which is worthy
option at the Foreign Office and you've
got an official building in Berlin
you've got your work does how do surely
there and suddenly constraints or maybe
well no there are changed effing it
there's definitely changes because after
all this is you know the other places I
just choose the images out of my head
box of images and here it's a library so
I'm sure I'm deliberately obviously
choosing books there's a there's a
reason suddenly further to be an image
rather than some decision that's
arbitrarily mine and then I and this was
the first time this has happened in
quite a bit of what I've done where
there's a kind of mixture of signage of
pictures of images and and signage and
the and that the work almost starts to
stand starts to stand in for the thing
that it's there's referring to in the
particular in the particular context the
other thing is of course this this was I
have to say this was intended and I
thought of it as permanent it is already
gone but that but that made a very very
big difference the sense where's all the
other vast things that I've done of
course were destroyed and but I mean I
they were only on for a month or two
except for the one in books to who do
and I've but I've o people have often
asked me whether the troubles me I mean
you know but it never bothers me in the
slides because I know that nobody would
ever have asked me to do the things that
I thought they were gonna have to live
with them forever they did them because
I was allowed to do them because they
were temporary and one of the things
that's great about contemporary practice
is that you can do extraordinary things
now on it that makes sense as a
temporary thing which would really make
no sense or something more permanent
this is another this is another
prominent installation this is in a bank
in Hanover it's the staff dining room
and once again this was this was done as
a permanent thing and you can see I
picked up certain themes about food and
serving and um this is the we're going
to now we're back in the museum this is
a room in the Tate it was in an
exhibition called intelligence in which
there were the room is completely square
and the images go around the room
this is in Manchester and this is on one
side of the room there is the bat
painting of the back of the canvas and
all these objects floating in the living
room and on the other side of the room
is a painting and all the same object on
the other side the room have been
crushed into a painting so as one is
kind of exploding the other is kind of
contracting wolfsburg
this isn'ta loose and the museum
entrance into loose this is something
some are different i did a wallpaper
using 11 different images and the images
they don't overlap but they all touch
each other like fingertip touching and
then I made 11 paintings one of each
object and the drawing and everything in
the painting is exactly the same as that
was a bit of the as the drawing of the
same thing on the wall paper so that
what it means is that you hang the
painting the painting of the bucket
everything you see in the pink picture
is paint is a paint on a canvas but you
can hang that picture any place where
the bucket appears on the wallpaper any
it could be up throw up higher and
beyond the other place so all the
pictures can be moved around the room
Pentagon where this is this is a
collaboration that i did with hertz are
in iran i had met them when they were
the architects for the Tate Modern
because I was an artist trustee of the
Tate during the period when the thing
was planned and the Tate is really quite
amazing the three of the trustees are by
statute have to be artists so there's
always three ordinances trustees and I
became very involved with them and we
got on very well and I was very
interested in how they worked and they
asked they were doing this dance school
also in London called the LOB and dance
school which is in the absolute worst
part of London and it was completely
derelict cited was a place here where
you burned tires and they built this
amazing building and they asked me to
come in at the beginning because they
wanted to do some color so we introduced
some color in the outside you can kind
of see it in there's a plastic skin and
they were they were the colors were made
specially for the building to go into
the skin so it's just a little bit of
color but the color the places for the
color are not determined by something on
the outside by but by what happens on
the inside I don't know if
I'll show it to you when it comes up
this is a then I did a wall drawing in
the lobby and I that's also in the
emptiness way and I also all the
corridors were painted in the same color
the these three colors different card
there were three different colors in
three different hallways and I'm sorry I
didn't have it but that what happened
with with the with the the plastic on
the outside is that in the dance studios
that would filter through the frosted
glass so there's a little bit of color
just fill tree into all the students
because students had different accents
so what so to me what's striking by this
point is that there's this flicking
between museum spaces or gallery spaces
and buildings and structures and
commissions and yet the work somehow
remains much more consistent in a way
between these two zones than then is
often possible how how are you relating
to the the the architect or the people
who are actually inviting you to work on
the building what's the process how
different is it are they is there a
different process of judgment is there a
different process of negotiation how do
you get to do a big fan on the side of
the building for example who is making
the ultimate decision is it the owner of
the developer or the architects that
this this line of communication i find
very interesting in the previous
building the dance school i was brought
in by the architects and the the the
client the dance school was more or less
unhappy because they thought it was a
waste of money and fortunately the arts
council have paid for me this it was the
there was a property developer and this
was a site in which they were rebuilding
the entire site and they just had one
building that they weren't going to
develop a tree de Velde and I what my
work was meant to hide the building
which I may say it very effectively did
and
it this too it was on is now gone
because they have now tore down the
building in order to put up the building
they always intended mm-hmm there was
intended to have but it was a very
interesting project for me because it
was the most public things is quite
central in London public space and it
had a vet this work had a very dramatic
effect because all the people around
there got to really like it people like
to see it from the bus because the
people who work there liked it and
people were very upset when it went and
it made me feel that there that there
there's that there are possibilities of
these kind of interventions through art
which can be quite dramatic but they can
change the character of a place in a way
that people actually like okay this is a
small public museum in Milton Keynes
which is a horrible little town outside
of London and the the building when I
got to it was two color two tones of
beige and the thing that was most
interesting technically here was that I
used exactly the same paints with
acrylic paint that I used in the studio
which is the most expensive hi it has
the highest density of pigmented of
virtually any paint you can get and the
entire building was painted in this
material so that this building where the
Sun hit it it just gleaned nobody had
ever seen a building look this kind of
color because there's never that kind of
color in the materials that are on a
building this is in the sorry it's very
recent that's if that's rather nervous
just super nice today I can't room a
very modest architect who was too shy to
make his name too well now
this however is ability by an architect
whose baby is very well known this is
the Sumter building in break-ins the the
quenched house in Bregenz which is which
is a fabulous building one of the great
buildings and I was able to do neon
drawings inside the skin there's a class
skin and that Indian droid is actually
inside the skin of the building there
was a light bulb on one side facing the
square and the other one was facing the
lake and then this is the this this is
done now this is now in the 2000s the
knots or whatever it's called and now
that the technology for digital printing
has become so extraordinary that I I
cannot as a temporary thing paint all
these images in different colors but you
can print it and I can't paint I can't
paint predations but these are dead easy
with digital printing and what's really
extraordinary ken's it was done by the
local people company that does printing
these things they have a 5 meter-wide
printing press printer and every ball
was a single sheet so some walls were 25
meters long and the whole thing is four
or five meters high so the the quality
and the capacity of these of the
printing is just unbelievable now and so
for any of these big projects I now
don't I'm too old to go up on the
ladders with all the tape and everything
and so but just at the right moment
they've managed to invent a printing way
that you couldn't do things and I can do
things now which I could never have done
this if I was peddling if I was painting
the paintings had a cut they had a
quality because of their simplicity and
their massiveness but you could never
get the kind of subtleties of color and
things that you can get in these
this was a church outside of break-ins
coincided with the exhibition and I've
put this picture in because you can get
a sense of how gigantic it is it's a
abandoned medieval church and the whole
all the walls that they're putting in
it's all on fabric again digitally
printed and they made a framework that
went around all the windows and the
walls and then they they stretched it
and stapled it on the walls I'm just
eager to get through to make it or we
see everything and then we can open
things up a bit more okay this is also
break ends from the top of the hill this
is the museum around Dublin again done
the same way with digital printing and
this is when about mrs. 2006 ok this is
painted on the walls these are this is a
public housing in in the South of France
and nice not along the coast where it's
very glamorous but in the backwards or
working-class housing and when they put
in the new tram line and nice they
commissioned 14 artists to do projects
at 14 spots along the route of the new
tramway and this was my spot and I did
this drawing of 8 images then every one
of the doorways has one colored image
from this thing
this is in Luxembourg and it's a drawing
of three globes interlocked and it's set
into the floor it's made out of corrion
I had a fantastic thing happened to me
in this project in Luxembourg because
DuPont was building a new factory for
Corey and I'm sure the architect smell
Orion and it's extremely expensive
material well this wall is four meters
high and it's 88 metres long is unbroken
there's no repetition in the drawing and
the entire drawing was done by using a
good thing too etch the computer guided
hecho that etched out all the drawings
into sheets of Korean about a quarter of
I'm half a centimeter deep and then and
then you've made rods of Orion which in
colors which you can you heat and it for
three minutes you can curve them and
then you can put them in and then they
send the whole thing's the entire thing
is made of Korean has the most amazing
quality is unlike anything else and a
fortunate thing was the DuPont paid for
it this is a tube station at a railway
station in london in voltage arsenal
this is done with a silk screening on
ceramic tiles once foot square ceramic
tiles every tile needed to be needed to
be screen printed separately so you know
i wanted to open up the discussion or to
invite questions but before i do that i
wanted to talk about this strange kind
of development in a way because to a
certain extent you've kept quite close
to your original intentions it seems but
of course as time changes in context
changes this will always cause quite
strange results
and one of the things I think that that
came up in one of the essays I was
reading was this idea about being torn
between analysis and feeling and this is
something that of course is very
difficult to talk about sometimes and
you have already talked about this idea
of self-expression and the complexity of
and in the way I'm kind of rejection of
this idea of self-expression but there's
definitely there's the sense of feeling
and you've talked a few times about the
idea that or people seem to like it or
people didn't want it taken away or
people would just smile and walk through
the building or it's almost a kind of
there is some sense of people there's a
sense of there being audiences or people
there to see things but then again it's
quite analytical and it seems that some
of the things you do are almost like
this inning and like bloody-minded you
know there's this thing you've talked
about before if every time you think of
something your next thought is the
opposite so maybe first you thought in
the library of doing something else but
you end up doing the books it's so dumb
so obviously it's been overlooked in the
way can you talk a little bit about
these kind of things because when we see
this it seems isn't this the perfect end
in a way it's good work it's public
transport and it's readable you know by
people my son can read it and he can
play with it and take away memories but
also of course it's the result of a
quiet analytical process or a kind of
bloody-minded progression through
through different times and different
moments I mean maybe we don't
accidentally wear anything here we could
have ended up know very well n/m it's
not is it is it's not uninteresting
because I mean my one of the things that
you know I felt it when I was teaching I
hated people telling me what to do when
I was a student I was very resistant to
being pushed around I felt and one and I
hated certain kinds of assumptions and
one of the Sun turns I quickly came to
hate as a student was the idea that if
you paint it this way it was expressive
and if you paid it this way it was
unexpressed and this was cold
and I thought I just could not get my
head around idea and because of course
anybody who's in art school knows that
some people go do through this whose
paintings are really very very cold and
there's other words to do it like this
and they're not so cold so there's
something about the assumptions of what
happens in terms of of what constitutes
expression what constitutes engagement
but that may be all that there are lots
of assumptions which underlie things
which may be mistaken they may be
misread that there are ways i've been
i've felt of that you know in my own way
was trying to find some way to do to get
the thing to do the thing it's not
supposed to do i want it i want to use
this this so so you get this thing
between something that is that it's in
certain that's very analytic and
conceptual and the other hand is highly
visual that's forcing you into this very
visual thing something that's very
that's that's obviously I'm not a stupid
person and yet I you know nothing gives
me greater pleasure than doing something
that's that's that appears at a certain
sense to be extremely dumb but if
there's a way in which the work from the
outset has a kind of link to a period of
desire for a kind of democratization of
practice meaning that things can be read
you can see it's a bottle you could even
put it on the shelf yourself you can
recognize the the picturing of the the
object it's something that's not
Universal but within certain cultures it
certainly I think it's a light bulb it
has this light bulb miss before it has a
brand quality or a feeling quality this
is a very kind of ethical or this very
has meaning right it has this kind of
and by the time we get to this year or
last year and in the sub in the in the
subway station you've got these things
that can be read that that could easily
be be they're not necessarily your first
read of them isn't necessarily what you
call high art as you can imagine it you
said I mean like you don't necessarily
imagine this is a clever art project it
could be it's very ambiguous about about
where it could come from
how do you feel about this idea of you
know the fact that that in in having
worked a lot in Britain I mean you've
written about this idea before that the
Britons strangely anarchic as well as
being very conservative in a strange way
but also there's I mean how do you feel
this the British context has affected
your understanding of what high art
means or what a kind of intellectual
practice means or these kind of it's
very hard question to answer i know that
i can answer it no I know but i but but
I mean one of the well I went to I went
to England my education was entirely in
the United States I go to England in
1966 I didn't mean to stay for more than
a year or two and now it's 45 years
later and one of the things that I
misunderstood in my own removal of
myself from here was that I was already
engaged in a certain kind of context of
ideas which were essentially American
and when I went to England it was it
wasn't there there were things like it
in certain ways and other bits were
missing entirely and it took me I think
there's a kind of slowness in my
development which came from the loss of
that original context within which I was
working in retrospect the funny thing is
I think I probably did the right thing
for many years I there was a disaster
but i but I bet in but now I wonder and
I think that and i know i mean you know
when we talk about teaching everything
I've been useful in England and I might
have been more useful there than if I
had been here I think a lot of things I
said they were very ordinary but it I
was the only person who was saying them
and I think this SI and I think there's
something about I learned so much about
the nature of history and i don't mean
history of just the sense of knowing
about the past but the way the history
of a place
in flex its entire view of the same
things and that the the same history
written in America is different written
in England and it's not even when
they're when the two are in battle with
each other when they have when they're
sharing the same the British account of
World War two is completely different
than the American account of World War
two one of the things you said as well
as that in a way it's the most secular
country which in a strange way I kind of
agree with you I hadn't thought of it in
that way but it does seem to be it's not
as exciting country be maybe more
exciting but secular that seems to be
the case can you comment on that I mean
what one thinks that seems to happen
therefore is that my experience and one
of the reasons I I kind of often
desperate to get out of the place is
that people often ask philosophical
questions without wanting to hear a
philosophical answer which is incredibly
frustrating so the question is it art is
much more frequently asked in Britain
and it's something that will come
through quite populous newspapers but
it'll also come through someone standing
in the gallery on the Sunday afternoon
I've had the experience of being the
docent at the serpentine in in in and
people coming in to hear a talk on john
baldessari or something and then their
only question is is it art but that's
such a complicated question potentially
but without any desire to hear the
answer I wonder how you in a way how you
survived was it this without wishing to
keep coming back to educational
environments but was it this context of
Goldsmith's that was useful or was there
another context that took place in
Britain that allowed you to function I i
mean i have to say that I ended up but
when I when I go to England the 60s in
the sense that there was an art world
already in New York there were many
artists in England there were many more
artists than many more interest your
honor than I ever imagined before I got
there but but there wasn't was what we
would now call in art world there wasn't
the soup the kind of structure of
interrelationships and things that
existed here this now exists in England
but it didn't it didn't at the time and
the thing that replaced it were the art
schools and London it's six arts
and each art school was an intellectual
island and to teach him to teach at
Goldsmiths meant enormous you said the
minute you said retarded cosmas you
would said so much about yourself which
was completely different than if you
said you child Chelsea or you charted
st. Martin's that meant something
totally different and so there was the
life of the artist community existed
between the schools it's interesting
that I'm not sure which is the egg in
which is the chicken but the today where
there is where there is where you can
say there is a genuine art world the
schools have become much less important
in the way that they once were
interesting and they certainly don't
they certainly don't control the agenda
in the way that you could have seen them
doing so at the time when you huda and i
will first work you in the in the 70s
and in the 80s they they really defined
our world and they that's not true
anymore and so there was something else
I was going to say about this the
secularism of Britain and something
about this odd thing about the British
you know is it art it's sometimes
forgotten that the British went through
a period of unbelievable iconoclasm in
which the statues were hacked out of all
the churches crucifixes were burned on
you know outside churches there were all
these things were destroyed though all
the stained glass windows were all
destroyed there was an amazing there's a
hundred years of getting rid of things
and bearing things and getting hiding
things that could be hidden and so
there's something about because I was
educated in the 70s I am not aware of
what period that would have been
specifically exactly you draw a picture
about it your project about it but they
can so you're talking about the
Reformation or this well yes I mean
there's the monastery to destruction of
the monastery which is Henry's un I mean
the aircon with yet every 15 something
it's a 10 to the 8th and then
sorry to his it's just a benefit show
everyone knows that and but but the
thing is you see that it seems to me
that there's also something wonderful
about the English question is it art
because you can see that as pain in the
ass ignorance but it's also a kind it's
a kind of way of saying it's really
doesn't it is kind of important and
there's something about a people who
destroy if you why are you destroying
all the stuff unless you think it's
really important unless it is a power
and you're a little frightened of it why
are you by going through this you don't
need to do this and this and it seems to
me there's a residual thing in British
life of all the one hand saying it's all
rubbish and it's nonsense and it's all
kind of we don't need to know
anything about it but they're the only
people who worry about this question and
it's as though it kind of haunts the
society haunted in the society and so
it's interesting that now at this period
that the British have come back to
feeling comfortable with their own art
again which is one of the great changes
in the last 10 or 15 15 years to a point
that it's unimaginable to change whereas
who knows how this happened but I can
say now it like officially open for any
anyone who has questions so yes good I
don't know if we need a microphone or
not who's very interested in what you
were saying just now about the Buried
repressed kind of fascination with the
image and with this in a way it's the
the thing that's most guilt-ridden and
haunted about England is Catholicism and
this comes out a Hitchcock who is a
Catholic and everyone is supposed to be
guilty in Hitchcock it's been pointed
out again and again and I noticed
there's a residual kind of repressed
moment or peeking out moment of
Catholicism and your work in the
Eucharist because you talked about the
accidents and we look at the water glass
and we're told insistently in the text
that it is in fact an oak tree and it's
just like the Eucharist now the reason
why I'm bringing this up is not because
I want
pigeonhole at it historically it's
because of the insistence there and you
must have had an Irish Catholic that
background in America which was then
transplanted so it's a very complex
thing I mean I of course the oak tree is
based on the notion of transplant
association which transubstantiation
which and if I hadn't been a Catholic
grown up as a Catholic I would never
have known such a thing I mean it's only
Catholics who really understand the
power of such an extraordinary idea it
is an extraordinary idea that this thing
is not the thing that you see it no it
to be and it and that that fascinated me
obviously but I was doing the oak tree
as because it carried so many resonances
into art that I had never really thought
about until I I was trying to do
something that was all that as a I was
trying to make something very very
extreme in terms of accounting for
everything and doing nothing yes what
well I mean that that was my wrote the
text you see because i thought the work
had to have the text in order because
otherwise people to think i was just
changing the name and that's just boring
so as I needed and the text also then I
decided what the text should be in a
form of a dialogue because the dialog
aloud certainty and doubt it allowed the
author and the audience belief and
non-belief so that the discourse is
always between these two things so it
kind of him it kind of collapses all of
those things that happen in work sort
into this one little thing but what's
very common is when someone does
something that is this work was
definitely picked up people spotted it
immediately it was even semi scandalous
in the context with it was shown
originally as far as I'm aware of course
is a great temptation to try and do
another one you said I mean there must
have been a great I mean there would be
normally you've got one of the things
that artists usually have even if that
chin as well is they have time I mean
that's what they do they think about
what to do so was that work away of like
killing something off in terms of
intellectually speaking like saying or
was it did you try and extend it did you
think there could be a way do you said I
mean whatever i floundered for a couple
years ago to figure out hows it to the
next thing and I have to tell you I did
do another work similar which I have
very very successfully suppressed so
that absolutely nobody it was shown in a
major exhibition in paris it was shown
at the biennale in paris at the same
year that the oak tree was shown in
paris and absolutely nobody has ever
mentioned it to me it just like it
didn't exist and I try to keep it like
that you're the only people I've ever
even talked to be posted sorry yes in
the middle you mentioned that you know
during discussing your early work you
mentioned how you would never attempt
not to be fixed in a particular style
and once you did something it was it was
retired permanently and then it seems as
though once you moved into two
dimensions you you did very much adopt a
style and it was kind of its varied ever
since to varying degrees and I I'm
curious about that transition and I'm
also curious if that had any coincidence
with with teaching and and if that might
have also contributed to fixing a
certain style I went when I first
started doing the drawings as I said I
tried to make the drawings stylist that
was my that's why they were drawn the
way they were not but then the stamp
that Tom Poquette would never took in my
in my own foolishness it didn't occur to
me that that would that might happen but
then again I never thought to be doing
it for so long and but there's there is
another irony in all of this which is I
have probably been more persistent
absurdly persistent in the i'm still
using images from 978 my whole or all
this work is like I'm having an
autobiography every time I make a work
because I'm I've got years and years of
things in all of this stuff but the
funny thing is that the thing I wanted
to do in the beginning that would allow
me to do lots of different things which
I when I tried to do all the different
ones it drove me crazy and made me
unhappy but now when I've got this one
thing that I do suddenly I am able to do
all those different things so I can I do
postage stamps I do the outside of
buildings I mean I've shown you all this
stuff because i'm showing you
architectural things that the actual
practice my actual practice is making
paintings I make sculpture and my pains
print side well you know I do a lot and
I but and I and I found that this tool
is unbelievably flexible so all that's
that range of stuff I had hoped in the
beginning and i thought i had to do
different things it's actually having
some aspect of it that you can keep
consistent that allows you to do the
different things hey this is a way less
intellectual question but i was
wondering a lot of what i was responding
to in your work was kind of the really
great juxtapositions that happen like
with a really old architecture and the
really bright colors and I just was
going to ask like the one place I don't
see it and I wonder how you feel about
this is when you were talking about the
huge digitally printed images it feels
like those are just really cold and I
know what you're saying about the
gradation of color but I guess like I
just don't see they get that that seems
present in all of your other work and
that's the one place that I don't see it
imagine the debt in the digital images
yeah i just i don't i'm wondering what
you think about that well i mean among
the prompts I mean I in that room you
know the room that i showed in break-ins
but first of all it's got the glass
ceiling that's got concrete all the
walls are concrete i did cover them for
me and it's got a concrete floor and
it's a vast space because there's no
columns or subsidiary walls but in a way
that the image that the photographs
don't show that was the most astounding
room to go into I'm I couldn't believe
it when I saw it because it was there
are certain things you do in life I
found it an artist you know when the fan
the big fan up on the showed you know to
live up when that when that was done it
was much better than I ever imagined it
could ever be and the same thing
happened in that room it was so I agree
with you that in a sense there there is
something about the distancing that
happens with printing and that thing of
simultaneity that happens I mean I find
even when I'm making prints the printer
now nearly always we he does a perfect
digital image of what I'm going to do
and then we do a screen print and the
screen bit is better I mean the digital
print is so fabulous you can't believe
it could be better but then you do it
screen print it is better it's got some
other richness that is if it's not it's
it's something about an imperfection in
its perfection in its perfectness
something about that and somehow that
sense that every single thing has been
done in it maybe it doesn't get it so
one at the back
if I
you can go back to it
oh yeah we've had that the lights I've
been up the whole time any other
questions well you kind of made the
transition between 3d the object itself
to into 2d and but then those 2d
drawings become so volumetric because
they're defining new structures within
the space and new perspective and give
some deep into the walls so how how are
you working in terms of volume now from
those 2d drawings and how do you modify
the space and how is it related for
example because noah days the
architecture is so flat in terms of the
walls and before in really antsy anelka
tech chure liking at it and so on those
walls even if the image word so flat
there were given some kind of thickness
to to to these walls how is it related
on how are you working in terms of
volume with those TV maybe there's
another way of putting it and talking
about the idea of illusionistic space
for example of course is much more of an
obsession classically and modernism in
art I mean the denial of Volusia mystics
basin in high modernism when one of the
one of the things that in the very first
times that I drew things on the water on
the wall the colored things not the
other things but colored colored ones
one of the thing I because I painted the
rooms you see I paid the room red or
pink or something and they were so
wonderful looking just like they were I
thought why am I going to bar the point
I just do this this is enough and then I
put an image on the wall and as soon as
they put an image on the wall you could
see the room and the funny thing was
that having something to look at made it
easier to see that your peripheral
vision when it was all peripheral vision
it's very difficult to look at something
without having something to rest the eye
on
and it seemed to me that that seemed to
me to be very interesting and I what I
want what I've always wanted I've never
wanted something too I've never tried to
pretend that these things are you know
like 3d and the movies but I but that I
do draw everything at three-quarter
perspective in order to emphasize its
existence in space it's very rarely
something that's in in profile I'm
always trying to get something to and
and partly that's a perversity because
when i first started to draw these in
1978 drawing things like i was drawing
them was about the worst thing somebody
in my position could do and drawing them
in perspective was even worse i could
have gotten away with it as silhouettes
but perspective because this was against
all of the orthodoxies of the moment and
it so the thing is when there's a lack
of those think when you know when does
it when there's an opening its best to
step through it there's another question
in the middle like that unless
Thanks I remember your work especially
the tape work that you were doing in
London I you were actually one of my
tutors and 96 97 and there was a really
beautiful tactile quality actually I
debrief some of your assistants to
figure out how it was made it was it was
actually a state secret at the time I
didn't do anything with it but I really
loved the sculptural aspect of it there
was a sense of you know michael craig
martin tangibility within each thing it
was a sculpture on the wall and I
noticed a sense of excitement with the
Korean that you were talking about when
you're presented the idea of heating up
something and putting it into a routed
computer routered groove do you how do
what turns you on as far as the i guess
the tactile qualities of work right now
yeah thank you you've introduced a very
nice subject for me because because it's
absolutely true I absolutely love the
physicality of things that which is one
of the reasons ever problem with the
digital printing it's the lack of
physicality and I all of the work that I
that I do if you see it in reproduction
it looks like there's a very little
physicality but actually it's very
slight as a county is very important to
me and I I think it's also important
that I make two dimensional pictures of
things which are usually associated with
painting but all of the workers actually
come from sculpture and I make pictures
of things like a sculptor I don't make
pictures of things like a painter and I
think that's very important and my whole
treatment of painting I see my paintings
as flat sculptures so I think we've got
time for one more question if everyone
has one and then thank you thank you a
small point of British history which I'm
not sure is true this idea of wrecking
icons wasn't it also done during the
English Civil War hundred years after
Henry the eighth's by
round heads it seems I remember seeing
some statues smashed in yes destroying
more than once destroying really just an
monarchical simple stuff so and that's
right but I think but I think that's a
very big and I I slightly I missed that
so I'm not now you're going to test my
knowledge of British history okay finish
on the knowledge of her making of
pictures the importance of pictures
because I think that they'd day one of
them skills of em MCM is to present
himself as innocent and there's nothing
nothing less innocent about these
picture making as he calls it since
indeed is is contacting questioning the
picture making and the simple assumption
that we make when we recognize a picture
we take it for granted naturally whereas
picture recognizing picture as picture
is far from obvious I've even the
Eskimos at a certain point in time when
they were still Eskimos could not
recognize pictures in the way in which
other the Japanese did not recognize the
shell under the eyes they thought it was
dipped in fact it took them a while so
in reality nobody recognized pictures
just as one doesn't learn to read and
write except when he does know and even
then it's true the strictures are great
by a given culture argument so I think
to dispense with it all together so
thank you very much
you